with his country besieged by russia
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
took another swipe at vladimir putin
formerly requesting membership in the eu
our goal is to be with all europeans and
most importantly to be equal he said
russia's attempt to shatter ukraine has
instead solidified international support
nato and eu members have promised
military aid they've closed their
airspace to russian jets and delivered
wave after wave of sanctions the u.s
froze the assets of russia's central
bank even historically neutral
switzerland agreed to side with ukraine
if ukraine does not survive we cannot be
surprised if democracy fails next at an
emergency meeting of the united nations
the sudden collapse of the post-cold war
era weighed heavily we are today at a
crucial and historical moment
too many times in the past the
international community has been blind
or too slow in front of unfolding
tragedies
vladimir putin called the west's
coordinated efforts an empire of lies
yet moscow's isolation only grows deeper
the u.s says it will expel a dozen
russian diplomats to the u.n it accuses
of espionage in a further blow turkey
limited naval access to the black sea
against that backdrop the pentagon says
there is currently no mechanism for
avoiding an accidental conflict between
nuclear superpowers and that has put
limits on nato's resolve for now the
alliance has no plans to establish or
enforce a no-fly zone over ukraine
donna okay jackson thank you